[Music]
Brendan Fraser opens up about why he
disappeared from the spotlight we
shoulder the 49 year old actor is back
starring in the new FX series trust and
he's opening up to G Q about why he's
been m.i.a from Hollywood for the better
part of a decade explaining quote I was
going through things that mold and shape
you in ways that you're not ready for
until you go through them Brendan says
part of it had to do with his physical
decline from doing stunt work revealing
that by the time he shot the third mummy
film in 2008 he was quote put together
with tape and ice
the injuries eventually required
multiple surgeries including back works
a partial knee replacement and having
his vocal cords repaired leaving Fraser
in and out of hospitals for almost seven
years he also opened up to the mag for
the first time about allegedly being
groped at a 2003 luncheon Fraser says
the claimed incident made him feel ill
and like a little kid and ultimately
made him retreat meanwhile Fraser says
quote I became depressed I was blaming
myself and it was miserable because I
was saying this is nothing this guy
reached around and he copped a feel
last month et caught up with the trust
star at the FX TTA's here's what he said
about returning to Hollywood
very often home Millennials young people
to me now that I'm stampeding towards
middle age and wearing cowboy hats
President approached me to say I love
your movies that was four years old
[Music]